i want to quickly say i was in a
restaurant two days ago having um a meal
with my executive producer jeff ross at
lunch and there was this couple sitting
near us and then they got up to leave
they never acted at all
you know like oh there's conan or
anything like that they were just very
chill the whole time and did a very good
job of pretending they didn't care and
then uh the woman got up and she walked
over to me and she said by the way sona
is a
saint and i said no she is not
we got into it we got into it she was
like well i think she's a saint and i
said uh she is many things and i love
her to death and she's great but she is
not she is not a saint and even you
would agree sona that you were not a
saint you know i'm not that's not a word
i would use to describe me but what does
it say that she thinks i am i mean it
just means that you're
you come off as terrible and i come off
wonderful well
people hear all the things that i do and
they still think i'm a saint
and conan you're a demon and i feel like
you're on both of my shoulders yes one
of you is on the right shoulder one of
us is on the right shoulder one is on
the left shoulder i think it's like you
know when you're looking at a sweater
and you think it's blue you think this i
think it's a pretty blue sweater and
then someone holds up a really blue
sweater i think that uh i i think in my
regular life i'm
an okay chap i'm a fine gentleman
but then there's something about when
i'm talking to sona and to gourley where
uh it's like holding two sweaters up and
suddenly you realize the sweater that i
am in this scenario is a [ __ ] brown
i'd go along with that
and you two are future these fluorescent
uh
you make us look like i make you look
good you do yeah so thank you so uh so i
just so matt you had a dream about the
podcast i'm told is that right well it's
funny you should mention sitting in a
restaurant because i had this dream i
was driving in santa monica which
already makes it a nightmare because i
never go to the west side and i i was do
you remember mccabe's guitar shop i was
headed i used to hang out at mccabe's
all the time uh in my early days like
working on the simpsons
isn't the simpsons uh the fox slot is
not too far from mccabe's and i would go
there all the time and try out the
acoustic guitars place was amazing yeah
anyway so i i was heading there and it
was closed so i went to eat at this
really shishy restaurant by myself
and i walked in and the maitre d goes oh
no reservation what have you done in tv
and film and i'm like nothing to speak
of really and and i said but i i i'm on
the conan o'brien podcast and he goes
right this way
and he sat me down at the nicest table
did that thing where they like brought a
table in you know
from goodfellas where they there's no
table but they bring a table in that
didn't exist before and put it down and
immediately said it beautifully first of
all why don't you just admit this wasn't
a dream and that this happens
everywhere you go
hi i'm matt gorlia
i don't have tickets to see
uh paul mccartney in concert uh
well if you don't have tickets you can't
go and see this legend on his current
tour i know what have you done not much
anything well i work with cona conan
o'brien
and then he has explosive diarrhea and
then he seats me on paul mccartney's
piano paul brings you up who's got a
surprise here you've got someone who
works with conan o'brien crowd screaming
hold on stop cheering for conan so i can
play hey jude still cheering conan and
conan oh come on everyone settle down
i'll sing a a beatles song we never
released for the first time ever would
you like to hear that conan and conan
conan oh this isn't fair conan's so
popular i guess i'll never get this
secret song the beatles wrote out oh
well might as well go home mistake to
bring goalie on stage conan conan conan
wait a minute i blacked out and told
that whole story
you did well that was the dream i had
and i'm sticking to it i like that dream
that's a delicious dream i thought you
might